- [Instructor] As we enter
into the sixth century BCE,
the dominant power in the region
that we now refer to as Iran,
it was the Median Empire.
And the Median Empire...
I'll draw the rough
border right over here.
Was something like that.
And you can see the dominant region
of Media right over here.
But, by the middle of that century,
they are going to be overthrown.
They're going to be overthrown
by one of their subject kingdoms.
And that is the Persians.
And so, right over here on this map,
it's called Persis, but that
region is called Pars or Fars.
And, even today in modern Iran,
that region is called Fars.
And the king of Pars was Cyrus the Great.
And, in 550/549 BCE,
he's able to overthrow
the Median emperor, who
happens to be his grandfather,
and then he establishes what history views
as the first real Persian empire.
And the whole reason why we
even call it a Persian empire
is because Cyrus the Great was from Pars.
Persian is really
referring to the idea that
the ruler, the dynasty
that gets established,
was coming from Pars.
It turns out, and I talk
about in other videos,
the Persians did not refer
to themselves as Persians.
They viewed themselves
more as the Aryan people.
In a lot of ways, Eran or
Iran or Arianum of Asia,
these types of words are
more accurate for how
the Persians viewed themselves.
But, needless to say,
in 549, Cyrus the Great
is able to conquer the Median
Empire and he keeps going.
And what he establishes,
this empire, this dynasty,
is called the Achaemednid Dynasty.
And you might wonder
why is it called the Achaemenid Dynasty,
instead of, say, the Cyrid Dynasty?
And that's because Cyrus claims
descendant from Achaemenes.
He is part of that family.
Achaemenes is this
semi-legendary patriarch of it
that lived 100, 150 years
before Cyrus the Great.
And so, I will draw a dotted
line from Achaemenes to Cyrus.
And Cyrus then goes on.
So, he conquers the Median Empire,
then he goes on to conquer
several of the major empires of that time.
In the mid-540's BCE....
So, we are right around there.
He conquers the Lydian
Empire, right over there,
which is on the western half of
the Anatolian Peninsula
in modern day Turkey.
And then, he sets his sight
on the Neo-Babylonian Empire.
And, in 539, he's able to conquer
the Neo-Babylonian Empire.
And, from a Biblical
perspective, that's relevant.
Because, when he takes Babylon,
he frees the Jews from
the Babylonian captivity
and he resettles them in Jerusalem.
And he works with them to
rebuild the city of Jerusalem
and, especially, Solomon's Temple,
which is now called the Second
Temple on the Temple Mount.
And Cyrus the Great is viewed by history
as one of the great rulers of all time.
Often referred to as a model ruler.
Someone who really takes the
interest of his people at heart.
So, Cyrus was able to conquer
a lot of what you see here in green,
but not all of it.
And, especially, he was
not able to get to Egypt.
That would be left to his son, Cambyses.
So, in 530, Cyrus dies
and Cambyses takes over.
And, just so you read how
I made this timeline...
And I made this timeline, really,
to help myself understand the various
shahanshahs or king of kings of Iran.
So, Cyrus the Great was the
shahanshah, king of kings.
And then, Cambyses II was the next one.
Is that, this timeline up here,
this shows who was in charge.
So, you see from 550/549
all the way up to 530,
I have it yellow and that's
'cause Cyrus the Great
was in charge of what is
called the Achaemenid Empire
or, I guess you could say, this
first great Persian empire.
What I have down here is the
best information I could find
on the lifespans of these people.
And, when I have these dotted
lines at the beginning,
that's when it's unclear
when these people were born.
So, there's different accounts that
Cyrus the Great might
have been born in 575 BCE.
He might have been born closer to 600 BCE.
And so, that's why I
have these dotted lines.
Similarly, we don't know exactly
when Cambyses II was born,
but we do know that he
took control in 530 BCE.
And so, that's why you see Cambyses,
you see this line right
over here turn blue.
And, actually Cambyses
ends up dying in 522.
So, actually, this should be like that.
There you go.
He ends up dying in 522.
But, before he dies in 522,
he is able to conquer Egypt in 525 BCE.
So, right around there.
And you can imagine that,
while he's conquering Egypt...
Let me keep drawing this family tree.
So, now we have Cambyses II.
He goes off, makes his
real goal to conquer Egypt.
And that's a big deal.
Remember, this is ending
thousands of years
of the rule by the native pharaohs.
These now foreign rulers start
calling themselves the
pharaohs of Egypt, as well.
Egypt becomes part of the
Persian Empire because of Cambyses,
but you can imagine with the
shahanshah, the king of kings,
off and doing conquest in Egypt,
it leaves a little power vacuum
back in the center of the empire.
And this is when things
get a little bit sketchy.
So, Cyrus does have another son.
Th other son is called Bardiya.
So, let me write this down.
So, there's another son called Bardiya.
And then, there's this other
character known as Darius,
soon to be known as Darius the Great.
And Darius is not a direct
descendant of Cyrus the Great,
but he is part of his family.
He's a distant relative.
He is part of the Achaemenid dynasty.
He claims descendant from Achamenes.
And he was the lance-bearer
for Cambyses II.
So, while Cambyses is
out here in Egypt leaving
that power vacuum,
someone who claims to be Bardiya
takes control of the empire
or is trying to take
control of the empire.
Now, some accounts say that
this is really Bardiya.
This is really the other
son of Cyrus the Great
and so there would be some
legitimate claim to the throne,
but there's other claims,
especially the ones
that Darius was later able to spread,
that, no, this was not the real Bardiya.
That this was a fake Bardiya.
That the real Bardiya had actually
been killed by Cambyses II before
and that this person
proposing to be Bardiya
was this fake usurper,
this Zoroastrian priest named Gaumata.
And, once Cambyses, on his way....
He's trying to come back in
order to reclaim the throne
or in order to get rid of this usurper,
whether it was the real Bardiya or not.
But, on the way, he dies,
once again, under dubious circumstances.
Cyrus the Great, how he died, not clear.
Cambyses II also dies under
dubious circumstances.
And then this Bardiya actually
becomes the shahanshah for real.
He obviously has claims to
it while Cambyses is there,
but, once Cambyses dies,
he is the shaanshah.
Well, Darius doesn't like this.
He has his own imperial ambitions.
He gets some other
nobility together and says,
"No, no, no, this Bardiya
isn't the real Bardiya.
He's a usurper.
Let's go kill that guy."
And so, they kill him and then...
It's an interesting story.
Herodotus has a fairly dubious account
of how Darius was able to
convince the other noble people
why he should be the
shahanshah, the emperor.
But they are able to get rid of Bardiya.
We still do not know whether
it was the real Bardiya
or whether it was the fake Bardiya.
But then, Darius takes power in 522 BCE.
And he's known as Darius the Great
because he continues to spread,
continues to conquer more and
more for the Persian Empire.
And this map, right over here,
this is the Persian Empire
in 500 BCE under Darius the Great.
It's near its maximum extent.
And it's a pretty incredible empire.
It's worth noting....
And it's big by any
stretch of the imagination.
But it's at this time the population
is on the order of 50 million people.
And, based on the accounts that I've seen,
that's almost half of the
world population at that time.
No empire in history,
as far as we can tell,
has ever had such a large fraction
of the world's population
under its control.
And so, that gives you a sense
of, I guess you could say,
how great or how large an empire this was.
Now Darius the Great, he is also famous,
especially from a Greek perspective,
for going after the Greeks.
You had these Greek revolts in these towns
on the west coast of
the Anatolian Peninsula.
They revolted against
their Persian overlords,
I guess you could say.
And they did that with
the help of the Athenians.
And so, Darius didn't like this.
In the 490's, he starts
going after the Athenians.
This is the beginning of
the Greco-Persian Wars.
He is unsuccessful.
He dies in the 480's and then his son...
This is actually a relief of
Darius the Great right
over here from Persepolis.
And then, his son continues
to try to take over
in the Second Greco-Persian Wars.
And he, too, is unsuccessful.
But, it's worth noting, a lot
of this history that we get,
especially of Cyrus the Great
and the early Persian shahanshas,
the history we get is from the Greeks.
So, it's worth taking it
with a great grain of salt,
because, as you can see, they were rivals.
And to say rivals is a little
bit unfair to the Persians,
because the Greeks were more of
a thorn in the side of a large empire.
The Greeks were this group of city-states.
They weren't even a unified empire.
While you had here the Persian Empire
controls almost half of
the world's population.
So, the Greeks were more
of a thorn in the side,
but we get our history from them
or a lot of our history from them.
So, we get their account of things.
Now, once you have Xerxes,
then, after Xerxes, you have
Artaxerxes, right over here.
And then, you have a little bit of a
squabble for the throne
and then Darius II.
There's one thing that you see
over 200 years of Achaemenid rule
is that most people,
after Darius the Great,
are named either Xerxes,
Artaxerxes, Darius II, III, IV,
or Darius II or III, at least, not fourth.
Artaxerxes II, Artaxerxes III.
So, it can get a little confusing.
But the reason why I
even did this for myself,
to see when all these people
lived and when they ruled,
is to have a good sense
of what was going on
and how Darius II lived
at a different time
than, for example, Darius
I, or Darius the Great.
The other thing worth mentioning,
'cause you'll hear this
in various history classes
when you talk about the Persian Empire,
is the great cities of the Persian Empire.
Cyrus the Great, he
establishes the capital
at Pasargadae right over here.
You have Cambyses establishes
a capital at Susa.
Susa is one end of the great royal highway
that goes from Sardis all the
way to Susa right over there.
You have Darius the Great
establish a capital at Persepolis.
And that's the Greek name for it,
literally referring to Persian city.
And this is a relief from
Persepolis right over here.
Now, the end of the Achaemenid Dynasty
comes when that famous
thorn in the side, Greece,
actually unifies under Philip of Macedon.
Here, we're talking about the
early to mid-fourth century BCE.
And his son, Alexander,
becomes this great conqueror,
Alexander the Great.
And he's able to conquer
the entire Persian Empire,
famously taking it away from Darius III.
We talk about that in another video
or in several videos in some detail.
But, Alexander the
Great, he has this vision
of one nation of these people.
Their cultures mixing together.
And there's a significant
amount of cultural mix
between the Greeks and the Persians.
But then, Alexander dies
and his empire is split.
But most of the Persian Empire
goes under the control of Seleucus,
who's one of Alexander's generals,
and then you have the Seleucid Empire,
which is really foreign rule of Persia.
And that will continue for a while.
Until, eventually, the Parthians,
which is, once again, another
state or region of the Persian Empire,
takes control to establish
the Parthian Empire,
which is one of the rivals to Rome.
It's worth mentioning,
and I mention this in the
video on ancient Persia,
that, under Persian rule, and Cyrus
and the various shahanshahs
were famous for delegating
their authority.
When you have such a large empire,
you can't control all of it yourself.
So, each of these regions had their own,
I guess you could say, governors.
And those governors were called satraps
and the regions were called satrapies.
Anyway, I will leave you there.
Oh, and the other thing that
Cyrus the Great is really known for,
is the spread of the Zoroastrian faith.
We talk about the Zoroastrian
faith in other videos.
And Zarathustra, who
is kind of the prophet
of the Zoroastrian faith,
he lived someplace between 1500 BCE
and might have even lived
shortly right before,
almost near the time of Cyrus the Great.
But it was really Cyrus
the Great who helps
spread this great ancient faith.